today's topic stephen crowder wasn't up
against h3h3 for a debate and everything
devolved
uh essentially what was supposed to
happen was that steven crowder was
supposed to have a debate with ethan via
some kind of zoom app and what ended up
happening
is that uh ethan switched out his screen
and allowed sam cedar who's a political
leftist commentary channel
on youtube to debate crowder instead now
the whole thing devolves from there
because crowder doesn't want to debate
sam cedar he wants to debate ethan klein
from h3h3
and a bunch of stuff gets set and
people were asking my thoughts on the
whole thing and so i went to go watch
and i couldn't stop chat
laughing and i'll be honest with you i
think they both look stupid
so here's why i think they both look
stupid first off on ethan's part
if you're gonna accept a debate with
somebody you can't switch yourself out
for somebody else stephen do you know
that um
the spartans are that they
are like uh practice man love with
children
oh geez okay so this is what's going to
happen i what did i tell you he was
going to do anything he could to avoid
oh oh there he is oh no sam cedar what
up
what a [ __ ] nightmare i had no idea
this was going to happen
if i come and i have a conversation with
you and then someone else comes in i'ma
feel some type of way off the top
because i'm like well who's this you got
tricked yeah like why would you
do something as crowder put it based off
lie
right fair which you know in crier's
defense
i i do think that was a slimy move like
and i think ethan
when they were kind of having the
conversation i was watching i was like
do you guys not recognize
how slimy that looks yeah and like how
smarmy you were being the whole time
like
listen you need some people around you
to tell you you're being a little bit
ridiculous in that moment that's shady
all right
now why didn't crowder look stupid
crowder
so samson is like yo i want you to baby
i've been trying for a long time and
this is what crowder said to him the
first thing he said
he said the reason i want to debate you
is because
you have less than one third of the subs
i have sam why do you feel that anyone
owes you airtime when you have a 40th of
the audience and you've been doing the
show
think anything i think i think that
ethan has just given it to me
i didn't ask him for it
so he can
that i only have a million subscribers
and you have what six or seven million
subscribers let me answer can i answer
your question can i answer your question
can i answer your question
you want to answer your question my
audience would say sam who just like joe
rogan's audience and ben shapiro's and
dave reuben
because you had to shoot on yourself
what that's the reason you want to
debate someone because they have less
subs
and i was like what okay well you prove
oh
wow you did not say that my bro
your your call to fame is a is a series
called change my mind
where you go on college campuses with
your binder full of facts
okay and then you just railroad people
strangers with zero following because
it's good for you
and here you have somebody who's you
know
knows their stuff who follows the lingo
who fought who has it you know
i think he has like a million subs same
seater you know majority report
and you won't do it it's even crowded
and i'm just like
what why would you go out of your way to
debate people who clearly don't know the
subject matter but then you have
somebody who does
and you're like i refuse to do it ever
but we've been saying that it was this
engine wasn't the way that you were that
he was doing thing was a bit
like
[Music]
it was a bit slimy and stuff like that
now you just prove it now you really
just want to battle people that don't
have a following so
that you're doing disingenuous stuff and
that is blown out of proportion people
know it is that how
is that what you don't want you want to
get someone that has less substantially
less following than you so that
if ever you say something that's out of
hand it doesn't get exposed like that
right but when you're going to get
someone that has equal following and you
then you you're going to be like nah you
know what when you [ __ ] because you know
you
that means that you're not doing this
it's not a oops you're doing this on
purpose but you don't want to get caught
you don't want to get caught you don't
want to call called out on it you don't
want those people that have
the same amount of following as you
calling you out on it and blowing that
[ __ ] up
that's what happens uh okay i'll say
this oh
stephen crowder makes me appreciate ben
shapiro
because for all the faults that ben
shapiro has at the very least
he doesn't do terrible things with
studies and two he actually has
conversations
with real politicians who aren't just
based off following you know he's had
conversations with roku khan who i
actually appreciate it was a great
conversation between the two
and he's a very like liberal
left-leaning uh politician so
i find it so crazy that crowder will
only debate people with followings and
yet he has the whole change in my mind
series it's like
it's it's one of the most paradoxical
things it doesn't make any sense
and i do think there's a reoccurring
theme with people who lean on the right
where they want to set up these debates
with people who are not politically
savvy
why would you want to debate h3h3
on politics when he's not well read on
it people come out abba you should
debate
uh stephen crowder why would i debate
him politics is not my realm
i'm not well versed in in social
democracies and all these different
forms of government
it's not my realm and he's disingenuous
and i don't care to study it that
in-depth
which is why our videos are not about
geopolitical situations all the time
but i can recognize when someone's being
disingenuous and they're being full of
[ __ ]
and i think that someone who's always
about like i'll change people's minds
i'm here to
bring the facts when you have somebody
who has their side effects and they're
ready
you run away that to me is the cowardly
part
and to use their following to lower them
as if they're beneath you
do you not hear how arrogant you sound
that's lame man so
you know that's just one of those things
that i couldn't wrap my head around when
i heard it because i'm like bro do you
not hear yourself
i believe we're born in the same town we
drained the same water
hey man you got to hold that l so that
was the first thing the second thing he
started clowning him on
climbing him on the fact that like your
show is irrelevant this and that
and he said and he caught he he was
caught slipping he said
why did you leave your live last week
early you're so pleasant
there's no idea that you were taking
your show off early last time coming in
today with your
pig pen peanuts i wish everything
you take those offers i'm like well if
the show is irrelevant
how would you know what how the [ __ ] you
got
you got guys living are you watching you
got you got you got guys listening
but why would you know something about
someone that's a oh
that's when the haters are a fan yeah
you know what you said stan stan
it's not all fans that are fans i like
you some people just watch you and they
follow you just to hate you
yo wow and then the third thing
is he started making fun of sam cedar
saying like are you a comic because i
looked up for your stand up which again
means you know who he is and you've
looked him up and i couldn't find
any good clips of you yeah you're a hack
comic you're not funny and sam's like
i'm not a comedian i'm just a political
commentator
sam fake stand up comic who we can't
find any footage about online
stand-up comic oh you're not okay that
makes sense because
everything that i've seen is incredibly
unfunny and unentertaining
explain the audience tyronn the irony
alert stephen comedian
appreciate our bro you gonna clown
people for being unfunny or funny or not
you're going to lobby that at them for
criticism when they want to have a real
debate with you
so you know the whole thing watching it
was a giant [ __ ] show
i think both parties were wrong and both
parties show poor
judgment in regards to how to handle the
situation but on crowder's side it just
showed a lot of disingenuousness
disingenuousness i just uh look up the
internet
and i try to find good clips of you
trying to swim
and you're not that good of a swimmer
you just alright
who cares not everything has to be
online
uh you're not that that's not what i do
like that you weren't even looking for
that
is cringey though oh wow you know what i
mean
wow he's like hey listen i'm not a fan
of steven crowder i've never tried to
look up his stand-up clips to be like
what are you doing so i know to me i
think debates are good
especially when they're done in a way
that you know maintains some level of
integrity
and even if like the debate devolves
because people are like talking over
each other whatever
at the very least you hope that they
come into it with some
some honest intentions this i think was
a poor judgment on ethan klein's part
and i think um
very revealing for crowder but i mean it
didn't reveal anything i didn't already
know
exactly you know it just proved it even
more
yeah and there's always going to be
crowder fans who are going to defend
them at any cost but it's just like bro
you won't debate somebody because of
their following really
you mister changed my mind it just shows
the color man
hey but you know what i'll never forget
when yusuf owned him when someone came
prepared instead crowder [ __ ] lost
his mind
but that that that proved the point yeah
once once somebody knows these stuff
he does a bunch of poor tactics to avoid
a real conversation okay
what about what about this other thing
yeah okay yeah yeah well okay well we're
not going to talk about that
yes we are that's what we're talking
about you saw it yeah i saw it and
this is also like a very right-leaning
thing even um candace owens
she's like i'll debate eoc but i won't
debate any of the like the large lefty
youtubers on the platform
because it's beneath me it's like so do
you want a conversation or do you just
want to own somebody that you think is
an easy mark
is that good for our audience to have
politically unsavvy people have all
these discussions and debates as if they
were
for marketing it feeds the ego of your
following
but you know that's why there's some
lefty youtubers that i enjoy that i like
that i think do a great job always a big
shout out to uh
well they're not with rising anymore
they're called breaking points but uh
you know chris and sagar do a great job
you know that's a right and a
left-leaning person who have
conversation on a daily basis so if you
guys want
more informed opinions definitely go
there but yeah you know those are my
thoughts
and uh anything else you want to add
about crowder why don't white crime
needs to stop
anyways let us know what you guys think
in the comments below we want to hear
from you
[Music]
is
no time for fake ones
that keeps you